[Music]
what's going on guys we've seen many
epic bromances in our time Matt Damon
and Ben Affleck han and chewie well
let's add one more to that list
Nik Mundi and the rock we sent Nik down
to the set of The Rock's new movie
Baywatch I'll tell you what Nick got a
little bit closer to the rock than he
expected
check it out
[Music]
hey screen junkies and stick money and
I'm on my first big set visit I'm ty
watch it's gonna be Totally Rad keep it
down rolling sorry guys my relationship
with the rock couldn't be stronger
we met in Miami Florida when Mark
Wahlberg mad-dogged me and the rock was
like hey man you're cool
a year later he stuck up for me against
my high school bully and then to top it
all off he married me to my wife he did
not marry me though that would have been
sweet too
let's go take a look around hopefully
the rock will vouch for me and I won't
get kicked off so uh Baywatch yeah
yes so I noticed you and Duane have been
getting real chummy on social media and
on set taking pictures yeah we're
playing around you guys have become good
friends lately yeah he's definitely a
great game no I know he's a great I know
he's a great guy because we're like best
friends how about you do that oh really
go yeah real okay that's weird he
married me a year ago and you like suck
up to a bully for me like we're just
really good friends but I figured he
would tell you dude that's awesome yeah
and tell me but that sounds exactly like
what you would do yeah I'm good for a
nap so maybe you guys are supposed
friends damn right
so you're kind of like like Duane's like
sidekick I see more like his best friend
Oh
but like you're just playing his best
friend you're not his actual best friend
you know
fiction reality they sort of blend when
you work so close to someone he just got
ordained as a minister to do my wedding
and it was so it was so funny because he
said I've done this once before but this
one's so much better and you're so much
better just like that being a human
being what what he said it was with this
guy Nick who was the total position did
you grow up as a big Baywatch fan
I did actually okay I did it was
actually the only show I watched growing
up we weren't allowed to watch TV when
we were kids only on the weekends
Saturday nights my parents would go out
and that was the only show that was on
okay I had three sisters so it was like
three little like six-year-olds sucking
their thumb like watching Pam and I got
an old moment when your parents walk in
it's like always a sex scene you're like
no it's not usually like this it's just
like grinding mom and dad it's just like
writing I was working with Duane like is
he like the best guy in the world yeah
he's just like you'd imagine him yeah
he's like y-you look and I just want to
hug this funny and great yeah it was
pretty much as close to a goddess
planted little posthuman yeah like Cuban
Taylor Swift
dude yes yeah they're both like
post-humans okay sweetly
I bought a Ford truck last week like I
bought a Ford truck because he's
sponsored by Ford I can't afford a floor
truck he just gave me one damn it
son of a [ __ ] I think rain comes back
waves coming today get footage it's
Wayne coming in fight every day how does
showboating
what's up hey welcome man thank you for
having me back let it go I'm not letting
go - where'd you make that a little bit
first off want to talk about Baywatch
yes were you like me and did you grow up
like a huge Baywatch fan like yeah I
mean my thing was I just I love the
beach yeah that's all I looked at when I
watch Baywatch okay I didn't look at any
other stuff you don't say no like the
bouncing in the I don't we were talking
about neither no but we were also like
15 and 20 then so we were watching it a
lot we were was pretty difficult thing I
was watching it professionally I was you
were playing pocket pool yeah wait let
me in
no get out mom man yeah bring everybody
now you've done so much for me I do for
you that's what yeah you do I do what I
do so are you friend you're like not
only the star of this but you're
producing it you're doing everything I
want I wanna what do you want buddy I
need a job how the [ __ ] do you go from
you do so much for me and now I want to
just ask you for a job
but I would have like work for I want to
do stuff for you oh I see what you said
yeah like I want to earn it
yes so what I would do is like you need
like a you need like security I don't
need security because I heard and I got
a great security team for Scott man I
don't need a Sun man even though you're
you're bad dude all right coach I don't
need an acting coach I got an idea
yes okay what job you got to take
incredibly serious because it's one of
the most important jobs on my team I
want you to be my oil man for your car
I'm talking about baby oil you put oil
on my body and it's so important ton
tell you why because we're on Baywatch
and they watch the Galibier grip yeah
yeah well I look ripped so yeah we just
got to bring it out okay with the oil
okay you down for that yes
oil oil all right let's do it
all right ready to do it right now yep
good it's a little slow though how's the
biceps it feels good I'm talking about
the muscle tissue tell me how hard it is
not always it is super hard it's dense
not to tell me you go tell people at
home it's throbbing it's it's everything
what you would dream it would be and
Eddie oh okay oh there's muscles I
didn't even know muscles exist okay it's
this thing
whatever that is called horseshoe okay
so horseshoe it looks like it you have
like four elbows but I think there are
muscles upper PEC there we go
there we go it feels there's just so
much strength like America that's right
this feels like America about to get on
a real Baywatch floor wheels yeah we
went a whole life for this yeah what was
that suede you need me to help save
people all right
[Music]
insurance will actually let me drive it
this is the closest I'm actually
breaking a couple Union rules right now
even being on this we should get going
I'm gonna get trouble so Zack Zack would
have left yeah I step in and and all
right cool you know what uh oil boy
Calabar we go yeah so at that time he
comes in or no he leaves and then that's
when I go in can you direct it to CJ's
little oh no not my nipple all right
listen so I got this one idea I think
when Mitch comes at that point he tells
the bad guy your mom right I'm fired let
me I'm fun let me call you back now but
I would like to sing in the Baywatch
song with you guys we're getting
everyone to sing it it's going to be a
big music video for the movie so people
stand in the darkness afraid to step
into the night some people need to help
somebody
windows in charge hello you were me it's
not me all right all right
cuz I'm always ready I won't let you out
of my sight oh good good rebel rebel
ways I'll be here
yes good that's good yeah good so listen
man I want to taste something we're out
here just me and you ready did a great
job today as my oil boy and and the
whole thing about the day was you want
to earn absolutely all right and you
earned it you're in something want to
welcome you to the team welcome to the
Baywatch team I'm going to give you some
that many people want but only if you
can ask Romo run down the beach
[Music]
well that was a good time I want to
thank everyone at Paramount the cast of
Baywatch and I want to say congrats to
NIC Mundy and the rock who have taken
their friendship to the highest peaks
and now will run off into the sunset
together of course in slow motion
check out Baywatch in theaters on Friday
May 26 so what TV show do you think
should be turned into a movie let us
know in the comments section below and
tell us why we want to know thanks for
watching screen junkies
I'm howl Roger hit me up on Twitter bye
bye hey guys did you know that this end
card works with your phone now I know
right click the boxes below to watch
more screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show honest trailers movie fights
and more